these are the recommendations from me
and the entire news crew
we're talking about things to read see
and listen to this weekend
up first one of my faves aina garten the
barefoot contessa herself
has a new cookbook out called modern
comfort food
look this is a picture of her grilled
cheese with chutney
i mean drool factor and aina
i don't mean to sound pressurey or
creepy or
you know restraining order-ish but i'm
just wondering if you would ever
consider coming on this show
and cooking in our kitchen when it's
safe or joining cookbook club and
recommending something jeffrey anyone
okay next on my weekender list by the
way i have every single one
of ina's books so just you know the
stalking is coming from a very positive
place i
promise that said i really hope you come
on the show okay
next weekend um next on my weekender
list get in your car
and check out a jack-o-lantern display
near you
they're all over the country this is a
nationwide event
so check your local listings but here's
a few on the west coast you've got
the knights of the jack and they're
super star-studded pumpkins
check that out and then oh in louisville
kentucky there's the
jack-o'-lantern spectacular
and if you're in the tri-state area head
to the jol
mecca the great jack-o'-lantern blaze
that thing is epic tickets literally
sell out like the second they go on sale
it's a very
draw-dropping display of squash
maybe i'll get to take my daughters this
year if we act fast
because we love halloween frankie
actually
loves she says she doesn't like being
scared but then she watches jaws
and the meg and she does like being
scared but we went to this halloween
store once and she cried on the way home
and she was like oh why
would you take me there and i felt so
bad
but now she's into thrills so we're
gonna try it again this nick
this year but halloween is just the best
okay
now for your ears i recommend listening
to the two funny mamas podcast
i love these women they talk about
everything they tackle
every single subject and with such great
flair
and comedy but they go deep i really
admire these women
sherry shepherd and kim whitley and they
just have me in stitches watch this
hold up i think teachers are calling me
the teachers
on mother's day they want to know where
is joshua's
why didn't you turn in joshua's work
they always ask me that about sunday
about where is joshua's work because i
was turning did you tell them
you're gonna turn it in maybe tape a
five dollar bill to it when you scan it
i love you guys and for your eyes i
mentioned this on the show this week but
i am newly obsessed with friday night
lights okay i know i'm late to the party
but as they say better late than never
or
as they say in dillon texas so let's
hear it one more time
together clear eyes full hearts
let's go oh i love it so much
if you haven't seen it yet or want to
enjoy it again
watch it with me and last on our list i
saw this on instagram and i had to share
it because come on it has brought me so
much joy
just look at these flavors of kitty toe
beans
i didn't even know that's what they were
called i want to die
just look at them oh and by the way that
is my cat
peach she always gives resting beef face
but look at her paws and that's my
other cat lucky okay so if you have a
furry little
friend turn over their paws and examine
what kind of you know paws they have so
no something to do with your cat this
weekend
you